is kevin mccarthy a [ __ ] and if so why
i said earlier in my comments science
science science and science
on almost every subject that you can
name science is the answer
whether it's the climate crisis whether
it's a health crisis
whether it's our preeminence in the
world in technology
science science science science if she
says science one more time she'll melt
[Applause]
[Music]
yes what a show
oh yeah so here's a perfect friday story
that doesn't involve brian kilmee being
locked in a men's room without his pants
again a man from washington state
wearing only a yellow dress
stole a bus and escaped from cops in a
chase
that resulted in him plowing a front-end
loader through his ex-wife's house
39-year-old andrew louden had just got
out of a psych ward
now there's a shocker but everyone's
getting out these days it's why kennedy
has her own show
yes so he allegedly stole the bus
last saturday evening and when the cops
caught up with them he refused to pull
over
he blew through a red light and instead
of pursuing the sheriff's deputies
ended the chase why because the new
police reforms
dictates that then another county's
deputies started pursuing him but they
also ended it too because of you guessed
it the new law
now if i were a jerk i'd say they gave
up faster than a gymnast at the olympics
but i'm not a jerk so i won't say that
after loudon ditched the cops and the
school bus he hitchhiked
to the city where his wife lived which
raises a question
who picks up a crazy male hitchhiker in
a yellow dress
besides bill hemmer
[Laughter]
what can he say he loves company but
whoever picked him up i can only imagine
the conversation in that ride you know
what's the medical bracelet for
how was the prom is that gucci also
please don't kill and eat me
it gets worse he then steals a front-end
loader
which is different than a back-end
loader that's the guy who delivers my
suppositories
a front-end loader is a machine with a
scoop on its front arm for digging up
earth
cat you could use one when picking up
your prescriptions oh
so he takes off in the front end loader
and uses it to smash into his wife's
house
flipping a car into the home luckily the
suspect's
ex had already fled he was finally
arrested all in all no one was killed
thank god
but really that's just luck you see the
problem
the police reform laws reform it sounds
like a good thing
they make things better but in this case
they did for the cross-dressing maniac
it's like liberals are classically
trained in the art of wordsmithing
you're not for abortion you're
pro-choice you're not an illegal
immigrant you're undocumented
you're not a living sack of poop you're
chuck schumer
[Laughter]
and they've done mean jokes always work
and they have and they've done this and
they've done the same thing with reform
but so far these reforms put people's
lives in danger
by pretending not to in this case police
are now only to
only allow to pursue suspects when
there's probable cause of a violent
crime
i guess fashion crimes aren't included
the driver has to pose an
imminent threat and somehow a multi-ton
bus
driven by a madman doesn't qualify it's
not like he was picking people up and
taking them to the outlet stores
now if he was wearing a make america
great hat may it would have been
different right
besides it was a bus not a maserati you
could have sent a mall cop on a segway
i've seen biden shuffle to the bathroom
faster than that
loudon is now held on charges including
theft of a motor vehicle malicious
mischief and not wearing an underwire
bra
meaning he'll be out soon so we're
living in a time where we're told
we must reform the police because we
assume everything we're being told about
the reforms by the press
was urgent and good for us they're like
parents trying to get their kids to eat
spinach
except the spinach only makes the
criminals stronger
the worse reform the no cash bail once
you arrest an offender you can't hold
him
because that discriminates against
suspects who don't have cash on them
and the last thing we want to do is hurt
the feelings of a broke mugger
i'm willing to bet however that most
criminals don't have money for
bail they're not mugging people so they
can contribute to their 401k
so bail as it's meant to be shouldn't
even consider the suspect's finances
this is nuts some of the most recently
arrested thugs in nyc have racked up
dozens of prior arrests
think of all the victims who've been
permanently damaged from that some are
dead
and there's new reforms in california
releasing butt loads of criminals
claiming they're non-violent which is
and now you can't arrest a shoplifter if
he steals anything less than a thousand
bucks
do you know how far 900 goes at a cvs
that's five bottles of pantene ten tubes
of preparation h
and one gillette shaver that's the kill
meat package
but i envy the thieves because they
don't have to carry a receipt
longer than the tax code so who needs
the cops when you can just tell the
crooks
what's an acceptable crime of course the
people getting the shaft when the stores
permanently close
it's the locals often minorities and
elderly who suffer
fact is today reform is a fake word
designed like a trojan horse to usher in
some seriously warped ideas about
justice
but what do i know i think stealing an
entire bus and going on a high-speed
chase
is a crime worth pursuing whether you're
in jeans
or the latest from the vera wang
collection
tonight's guest he's
written six books in red half as many
boston friends co-hosting
she still mom-arms her kids when she
drives through an intersection
host of kennedy on fast business network
kennedy
while everyone on this panel was smoking
crack he was fighting a war in iraq
host of the podcast rob smith is
problematic rob smith
and she always has the last laugh
because anyone who hears it
immediately wants to die fox news
contributor
cat tim
happy friday brian thank you what about
the others just me
no i'm going to you first because you
own a yellow dress and a front-end
loader
it's layaway gradually by the end of the
month it should be mine
oh yeah the the layaway my parents never
did that really
congratulations they always told me it
was on layaway right and
to say hopefully uh layaway uh how's fox
and friends
that is that is the worst opening
question that sounds like an insult too
but it
doesn't make any sense right it doesn't
leo okay so you don't even know we have
a morning show you get up at noon with
your life
i said last night to our guest uh the
dude what's his name todd
pyro that i've never seen fox and
friends
i've been on it well yeah he hosted it
what are we talking about jaysa boudin
you know who that is yes
the d.a san francisco san francisco i'm
gonna go to you kennedy enough from you
brian
i didn't do anything go ahead you sit in
the corner and i'm gonna come back to
you after kennedy all right fine
sometimes i wonder he when he when he
hears about these uh uh these
shoplifters
he wonders if they are just desperate uh
he maybe they might be part of a
criminal enterprise but uh
they might be the ones that are being
victimized yeah he's he's the district
attorney in san francisco he's doing
as much harm to his city as a district
attorney in
portland mike schmidt and uh these
people are
activists yes and they don't they don't
look at data they don't look at
statistics they don't talk to crime
victims
and the people who should get out well
they do but the people who really
shouldn't especially the repeat
offenders that you talked about here in
new york city
if you are going to commit felony
assault you probably should not be out
waltzing around
committing further crimes yes and
i i disagree in that i do think that
there are a lot of reforms that need to
be undertaken in this country
in terms of policing and criminal
justice but
you know this just blanket horrific
of these edicts that come from da's who
refuse to charge
really bad people it is making once
great cities crumble
it is it's true so brian have you i've
heard of my lesson yeah i really
love you guys online before and i just
like to apologize all right so i'm gonna
give you back your bike
okay thank you okay but stop riding it
to the adult theater you're right
there are no such thing as adult
theaters right they all should be adults
who go there fox and friends host says
all theaters should be adult theaters
i'm an anti-kid you're an anti-kid in
pro porn
i'm dying to answer a question okay what
do you make of these reforms
you mean the reforms that they're
talking about or not happening happening
i mean i'll give an example uh they
decided to do that in chicago they said
if an assailant is getting away and they
get too far away
let them go right okay that's fine so if
you don't have great foot speed
good luck so you pick out a cop who's
working a block that you know you can
outrun
anything goes number two is when it
comes to this this guy's in a bus and he
has to let the bus go
and to me that's a perfect example i
understand with police chase being out
in los angeles i know sometimes they got
dangerous because the cops got too close
but the guy's in a bus unless it's the
partridge family
you've got to stop that bus the
partridge's family's always late to a
gig and they had
so many empty seats they could have had
the elo
electrolyte oscar they were a big band
they could have got the whole elo in
there
but i will say this on the cops reform
the police reform um
can i do that yeah yeah on police reform
i think you should improve it
just like for example if you watch
baseball you see the strike zone there
if you watch football there's an instant
replay you improve the game
yeah they should improve always they
they're probably the most apt to say
give me two more weeks in the uh give me
two more weeks in training
right i'm for that rather than rick rip
them said now do your job the right way
just just different ways to do it and
improve that's where the money should be
going
increasing the academy time going over
past problems
making everyone more worthy after six or
eight weeks well excuse me after
uh eight to twelve to eight to ten
months they go back to the academy for
one week where they get paid go work on
their skills
again because sometimes the first time
is the last time they have a work on
their policing skills
so many people in the partridge family
are dead right uh
danny partridge though survival is a lot
danny bonaduce yeah still
the manager's
david cassidy's dead right i think
shirley jones is
no her husband's dead jack cassidy died
in a fire
why am i going this rob so in new york
we have
rough we have catch and release but in
california they're not even catching
anymore
well first of all what is the parches
family
[Laughter]
is this live does he have to be on the
panel here's the deal
that's a that that is a booker's mistake
right how did he get on
susan
was this like a 50s thing people in
their 50s did watch it
okay so back to the police reform so i i
think that most people that have a
uh the sense that guy gave them know
that you know there are some police
reforms that need to happen absolutely
we can all agree on that
but they're going too far in a lot of
these cities look the first story
look some guy gets out of the loony bin
and then you know pops by a dress barn
and steals the school bus and then the
police aren't able to chase him like
that doesn't make me feel more safe
and then you were talking about this um
law that decriminalizes
thefts of up to 950 dollars there was
this uh
twitter this thing that went viral on
twitter that came out out of san
francisco
so these people were basically feeling
all of these clothes we're not
rushing yeah just waltzing out of the
store this is like a car waiting for us
like their uber
it's like they took all the stuff they
called their uber and then they just
waltzed out yeah so people are not
feeling like there's going to be any
consequences for this
exactly that's that's the thing i said
that they look like me boarding
the boarding uh a plane got my bags
getting in cat i have a theory would you
like to hear it yes okay
i how did the how did the most radical
elements of society
get in infiltrate this much and i think
we've spread ourselves so
thinly across so many ephemeral
distractions
this thing our phone everybody's so
enveloped and everything else that these
that the left the hard left took
advantage of it i think yes and i think
there's another thing and i also i also
have a
an answer to your question in your
monologue about the guy in the dress
okay um i know exactly how he got picked
up
because whoever was in that car was
super super liberal
and they were like i gotta pick this guy
up or i'm transphobic yeah
that's true it didn't matter if he had a
hospital bracelet on or he was just
stealing a bus and doing he was like
well you know i would i don't know i
don't want to be a bigot
yeah i'll be part of the problem that's
exactly how it happened that's exactly
how this happens
because any i have faith that this many
people are not
this stupid but they are afraid to say
this is insane yeah because they then
they're not the you know wokey woke
locusts of the of them all that's how
you pick up a
hitchhiker who clearly just you know is
losing it and was stealing the bus and
that's how this happens
the wokiest woke of woke back mountain
yeah
how about that that's great that see
that's why i'm sitting here
that chair and i'm over here yes exactly
okay hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else